Christina: Camille, welcome to AEI!
Camille: It's great to be back, Christina.
Christina: Oh, my goodness, do you know that
21 years ago, I don't know if it was today,
but close to today we were interviewed by
Ben Wattenberg, for the AEI program Think
Tank which aired on PBS, and the question
was, "Has feminism gone too far?" and I looked
at the transcript and it's amazing, because
all of the things we were saying are truer
today than they were 21 years ago...
Camille: Absolutely.
Christina: ...about the excesses of feminism,
and the victimology, the male bashing, the
panic over sexuality.
At the time, 21 years ago we were confident
that it would be corrected.
It was simply too, too mad to succeed, but
it's still here.
Camille: I know.
Well, Christina, we sent up early warnings.
You, heroically in the late 1980s, were in
direct confrontation with women studies professors,
at a time when...
Christina: At a time when, as philosophers...
Camille: Yes, at a time when I could not get
published and finally after my first book,
Sexual Personae was released in 1990, you
wrote to me, and told me of your problems.
And we'd discovered each other as allies,
and that our status, it seems to me as truth
tellers, is historically unchallenged.
And I think that people are going to start
to wake up and to realize, if they had listened
to us at the beginning, we wouldn't have these
problems now.
Christina: We wouldn't, and it was so obvious
to me, I was criticizing the feminist theorists
at the American Philosophical Association,
and what they were writing at the time was
just warmed over Marxism.
It was so much animus to American society,
to men, to everything, to art, to beauty and
it seemed to me, it wouldn't take long for
it to correct itself.
It was never corrected, and what happened
is you and I...we did...I believe won the
argument, and the journalists agreed with
us, and the court of public opinion was on
our side.
They won all the assistant professorships.
They just quietly worked.
They didn't care about criticism, because
all criticism is by definition backlash.
Camille: Well, a lot of people dropped out
of graduate school, the really free thinkers.
The independent minds couldn't take the kind
of conformism and the PC ideology that they
had to account out to.
I got letters like that.
Once I was known in the early '90s, letters
came from all over the country from former
graduate students who said they knew they
had no future in the profession, because of
a total, kind of brain dead attitude you had,
a servile, sicko fantasy that actually you
had to have to certain received opinions.
Christina: Absolutely and in our interview
21 years ago you mentioned this Kremlin-esque
feeling in feminism.
It was a Kremlin-like environment, so much
censorship and excommunication, and so forth,
and students today don't realize there had
been this purge of anyone who was a dissident.
I happened to have tenure when I started criticizing
it, but it would be career diminishing or
career annihilating to criticize feminism,
even more so today.
Camille: Right.
Well, when I was a graduate student at Yale
which was 1968 to 1972, I was the only person
doing a dissertation on sex at the graduate
school, and I had trouble getting a job because
of it.
I was the only openly gay person at the Yale
Graduate School.
There were a lot of closeted people, and I
didn't have a sex life, okay?
I thought it was important to me to put the
gay identity out there.
But from the very start, as feminism's ideology
cohered and solidified, I could not have a
single conversation with feminists, either
inside or outside the Academy.
They could not stand...again, just what you
say...anti-art, anti-rock 'n roll, anti-Rolling
Stones.
They would not take seriously anything that
has to do with biology and hormones or anything
like that.
I was completely ostracized, but I belonged
to the pro-sex wing of feminism, also pro
art, pro beauty, pro fashion, pro Hollywood,
all of these things were anathema.
Christina: Pro glamor.
Camille: Pro glamor.
But then thanks to Madonna, there was this
new dissident wing in the '90s, which won.
The pro-sex wing of feminism won.
Christina: Right.
Camille: But now we won all these gains, but
the institutionally entrenched, feminist commissars,
all right, have brought it all back to square
one again.
All the new freedoms we won in the '90s, in
the pro-sex insurgency are gone again.
Christina: It's amazing, and it's a kind of
axis of intolerance with deans, and fanatical
young feminists, and the United States government.
Because the Department of Education has sent
this directive to all the schools, that they
have to clamp down on harassers, and they've
defined it so broadly that it includes if
you overhear someone telling an off-color
joke, you can bring them up on charges of
harassment.
So we have this little reign of terror, this
hyper puritanism.
It's as though George Orwell's Junior Anti-Sex
League has occupied feminism.
Camille: It's truly Stalinist, absolutely.
Now I take a very extreme view which is that
colleges and universities should never interfere
in any way with the social lives of the students.
It's up to the students to regulate themselves.
If a crime is truly committed, it must go
to the police, so a lot of these problems
with stuff if universities would confine themselves
to education and not to the surveillance of
student's private lives, now our generation
won these freedoms.
It was in loco parentis when we arrived in
college.
Christina: Yes, parietal hours.
Camille: And men wouldn't be allowed in your
room, and then if they were there...this was
right before I got to college...but you had
to have your feet on the ground at one time.
They'd look through your door.
Christina: People managed to do things.
Camille: In 1964, when I arrived in college
our women's dorm, the girls had to sign in
at 11:00 o'clock at night whereas the men
could run free all night long.
So we are the ones who demanded that the authority
figures get out of our sex lives.
Christina: And we wanted to be as free and
as wild as the boys.
Camille: Yes, and they said to us, "No, the
world is dangerous.
We need to protect you from rape," and what
we said was, "Give us the freedom to risk
rape."
These are the freedoms that we won, and now
this younger generation of girls want the
parental figures back in.
It is deeply Stalinist.
It is deeply infantilizing.
It's deeply reactionary.
It has nothing to do with feminism.
Christina: It's fainting couch.
Camille: This is a retreat.
Christina: It's fainting couch feminism.
Camille: Victorian.
Christina: Victorian ladies...
Camille: Yes, it is.
Christina: ...swooning on this chaise, and
you've heard about the Safe Spaces young women.
I gave a lecture at Oberlin and Georgetown
a year ago and they organized Safe Spaces
for students who were triggered by...it was
a philosophy professor was going to reduce
PTSD because of what they objected to, is
that I might have some ideas that invalidate
their experience.
Camille: They're institutionalizing neurosis.
It's what they're doing.
Christina: That's absolutely true.
Camille: It's absolute madness.
Christina: Have you heard the phrase, the
fashion on campus now is called intersectional
feminism, and it's supposedly very progressive?
And it's going to take feminism to a place
where it is taking account of women with multiply
marginalized identities, on and on.
But all of the women, the practitioners, seem
to meet at the intersection of propaganda,
and neurosis, and rage, and they're bullying
people.
They're using feminism now.
They're telling men, "Check your privilege."
Camille: Well, I think it's a good idea that
feminism be critiqued by class issues.
Because what I have said all along is that
what is being demanded is a bourgeois protection,
a white middle-class girl style, the perfect
little girl emerging from her parents living
room wants the same kind of protections on
the college campus.
So I've always felt there was a bourgeois
element in this that was never sufficiently
critiqued.
And then what I see on the street are Latino
women, African-American women who may be middle-class,
but have a working class background, as I
did as an Italian from an immigrant family...who
were able to handle themselves on the street,
able to speak back.
Don't mind having strong voices and strong
gestures.
Christina: Well, intersectionality started
with those women.
So it was a group of African-American women
who were just setup with the Women's Movement,
attending only the needs of highly professional,
upper middle-class women, but it has been
appropriated by mostly middle-class white
women on the campus.
So Safe Space was actually a word that was
used early in Black Feminism, as where black
women and Hispanic...places where they could
just talk to each other and they weren't censored.
They could speak their minds.
But now it means a place where, for example
young women at Brown University if there's
a debate that upsets them, they flee to a
Safe Space where they...It was described in
The New York Times by Judith Shulevitz.
They had coloring books, crayons, tapes of
frolicking puppies, bubbles and this is what
feminism has come to.
Camille: It's what education has come to.
Absolutely the definition down, they're therapeutic.
What can I say?
Therapeutic resorts is what education has
turned into.
Christina: So they have feeling circles.
They have reflection journals, and it's this
odd mix of therapy and anger because the word
for this style of activism, they call them
Cry Bullies because they combine...they're
both victim and victimizer and they do to
other people this new style of campus intersectionality.
They actually do to other people what they
claim was done to them.
They treat people...they objectify and they
stereotype, and they demonize and then they
try to get people punished.
Camille: Well, Christina, this is coming from
the public schools.
It's coming from the public school education,
which was devoid of knowledge of world history
and world geography.
It is nothing but naval gazing and the diversity
training, and all kinds of instructions about
social interaction, when in fact, if the atrocities
of history were revealed to young people,
they would be able to put their own little
hurt feelings into perspective.
Christina: Into perspective.
They have no perspective.
Camille: No.
Christina: I think with these anti-bullying
programs, they are learning that even the
slightest insult is a major event.
You must bring in the adults.
"It was terrible.
He called me a name," so they come to college
thinking that if someone disagrees with them
or says something that's distressing, that
it's a catastrophe.
Camille: I've called my feminism Amazon feminism.
I've called it Drag Queen feminism, Street
Smart feminism because the drag queens of
old knew how to handle themselves on the street.
They could be a six-foot tall, African-American
guy in a dress and he knew how to pull off
his high heels, and defend himself on the
street, and what a tongue they had.
And now everything is about weakening students,
not strengthening them.
Christina: Oh, it's exactly that and now let's
talk about the young men.
Can you imagine being a young man on campus
today?
And what I see happening is it's just the
way society used to police the sexuality of
gay people.
It's now open season on the sexuality of heterosexual
males.
Camille: Absolutely.
Christina: They're monitored, and policed,
and demonized.
Camille: ...and neutered.
They're neutered.
By the time they get to the Ivy League, they're
neutered.
Everything's been stripped off of them.
They've been made to feel ashamed of anything
virile.
They have nothing to identify with.
Christina: They're taught their masculinity
is a pathology in need of a cure and then
it's offered to them in these gender studies
programs, and it's not just gender studies.
Now this philosophy that demonizes men, it's
throughout curriculum and you're absolutely
right, it's going on in the high schools.
Camille: It's coming early on and so then
can you wonder, "Why are video games so violent?
Why is there so much porn on the web?"
Why?
It's because the imagination is being repressed,
and censored, and forcibly cleansed of anything
that's authentically animalistic or sexy or
vibrant.
So you have all the imaginative energy of
the universe now going into these other forms
where it becomes much more violent, and when
people see it, they go, "Oh, this is atrocious.
This is so awful."
But guess what?
You've made a whole area of life impermissible.
You've made all kinds of human desires and
fantasies impermissible and so it has to come
out someplace and that's where it is.
Christina: That's right, and what happened
last year was a group of cultural critics
from, I guess, liberal arts colleges started
writing for magazines for video games, I mean
websites.
And these cultural critiques started to attack
the gamers, and tell them their games were
sexist, and that they were contributing to
the rape culture, and the gamers were not
like the young men at the Ivy League.
The gamers fought back.
This became known as Gamer-gate.
The press has completely misunderstood it,
and the defamed the gamers.
They were just defending a hobby that they
love.
And I made a video about them in my Factual
Feminist series and defended the gamers and
then they started to call me Based Mom.
I am a mom.
But being based means being authentic, genuine,
no-nonsense and cool, so that's good, and
so I'm Based Mom on Twitter.
You, I've been talking about you and sending
out your things.
They call you Based Goddess.
Camille: Oh, for heaven's sakes, fantastic.
It's a wonderful compliment.
Christina: So the gamers, they appreciate
what we're doing because they have defined
the battle all by themselves, and there are
subcultures out there.
Groups of people, hobbyists who read comic
books, and now these gender critics are coming
in.
They're not just at the universities.
They're in all of the subcultures, and turning
them into very unhappy places.
But they made a mistake when they went after
the gamers because the gamers fought back,
and the gamers know a thing or two about winning.
Camille: Well, the entire world of animation,
and video games, and cartooning, this is all
a pure imagination and it must be protected,
like art.
Christina: It's the art, and the world of
gaming is diverse, and if groups of women...there
are a small group of very cool gamers.
It's mostly guys and a small group of women,
but if women, I don't know.
If they want video games about Downton Abbey
they can make them.
Camille: You see when you're not exposed to
complex works of art, like Dostoevsky for
example then you end up with a simplistic
view of human life.
You see this Utopian view.
Somehow everything's going to be like butterflies
and birds, and so on.
The dark side of human existence is completely
missing from these people's experience or
study.
Now our generation, I think was more realistic
because our parents had been part of the Depression,
World War II, the Holocaust was huge...
Christina: Absolutely.
Right.
Camille: ...and so we had a sense of reality
about what is important and what is barbaric
in human history.
This idea that you can micromanage reality
down to the pleasant is a Doris Day view of
existence.
It's so reactionary.
People don't realize it's sentimental.
It's middlebrow and it does not belong on
the college campus.
Christina: They are sanctimonious.
The sanctimony alone is enough to drive you
mad.
What the students are doing now and this is
at Oxford University...I think you know about
this...the young women are demanding trigger
warnings for anything that's violent or unpleasant
in a classroom, and so I'm thinking again,
trigger warnings in a history class because
you're going to study...?
Camille: Also law.
I think it also had to do something of law.
Christina: Oh, yes.
Camille: It had to do with rape cases.
They had to have a trigger warning.
Christina: Well, there's a group of professors
at Harvard Law School who are opposed to it
because they have young women who are going
to be studying law for some of them to be
litigators, but they do not want to hear even
the word, violate.
They've been asked to excise upsetting terms.
Well, what kind of world are we going to have
when these people graduate?
Camille: It is so regressive.
It's like the era of the Hollywood studio
production code when violence was also censored
on not just sex.
And that's why Alfred Hitchcock's Psycho in
1960, it changed the modern film and opened
it to all kinds of representations of the
reality of human existence.
I think that from what I can see, most feminists
seem to lack a sense of psychopathology.
They don't understand the most extreme manifestations
of human psychology.
So again, they think they can micromanage
everything.
They think that they can somehow fine-tune
the entire world to be entirely safe.
The world will never be entirely safe for
any human being, male or female.
The idea that somehow a girl going out at
night alone, as long as everyone has graduated
from an elite school will be somehow protected
against an attack from a maniac...
Christina: From a maniac, from psychopaths...
Camille: Exactly.
Christina: ...and that if you tell a young
woman, "You should not binge drink, and then
go out and walk around.
You're courting danger."
"Oh, well, tell men not to rape.
Don't tell us what we have to wear."
Camille: It's called blaming the victim.
If you try to give good advice to be street
smart about how you dress, and how you behave
and to be aware of your environment, and know
how to handle yourself in a potentially dangerous
environment, that's called blaming the victim.
It's absolutely crazy.
Christina: That men aren't predators, but
there are predators among men.
Camille: There are truly insane people.
The human mind remains primitive.
The human mind remains half-animal, but of
course, if you completely remove biology from
your consideration...
Christina: Then you're going to end up...
Camille: What's the first thing they do with
this kind of Girl Scout code, they have a
Girl Scout view of how...
Christina: It's all socially constructed,
so we can just re-engineer...
Camille: They're Utopians.
They're in this fantasy world.
They think they can produce a sexual utopia.
But all of the excitement and interest of
sexual relations comes from potential danger.
Guess what?
Gay men have known this for thousands of years.
Gay men go out everywhere around the world,
and court danger and death every time they
pick up a rough trade on the street.
It happens all the time.
Do you hear gay man complaining all the time?
Gay men trying to micromanage the entire world,
so they can pick up strangers in bus terminals
without danger?
No, gay men find the danger a kick, now why
is it then that men have that kind of more
sophisticated sexuality?
But no, girls are still children.
We must always protect them.
They're tender flowers.
It is so regressive.
This is not feminism.
Christina: I know it.
Camille: Nor is it modernism, as you say Victorian.
Christina: It's Victorian, and it's also feminism
is full of so many bad ideas that should have
been laughed out of...for example, this idea
of “the male gaze” and they use this,
"Woman is treated as object passive, he’s
the agent”…
Camille: It's Laura Mulvey's idea from the
1970's.
Christina: Exactly.
Camille: It's absolutely just a polluted film
criticism, and Laura Mulvey's a very nice
person.
I've met her at the British Film Institute
in London.
Christina: I think she changed a little bit.
Camille: But she knows nothing about the visual
arts.
You cannot just wade into film criticism and
start talking about the male gaze without
knowing something about the history of art,
and of perspective and of vision, and so on.
The male gaze is a foolish idea, it should
long ago been discarded.
Christina: And it's not as if in gay culture
we don't find the male gays.
I mean gay males enjoy looking at pictures
of beautiful, idealized...
Camille: And there you disproved a theory.
Because gay men know when they look at a beautiful
young man that they are not creating some
sort of powerful subordination on that man.
They know they're looking up in admiration
at that beauty.
It's been part of Western art since the Greeks,
for heaven's sakes.
Christina: I mean men look at women, and yes,
they're enjoying it, but they're also often
intimidated.
Camille: Very intimidated, and biologically
it appears to be that the visual apparatus
is much more connected to male sexuality than
it is in female terms, and this is what women
don't understand.
They think they can put on every kind of sexy
costume and it's merely décor.
That it does not carry its own message.
Christina: Right.
Camille: Because they don't see things as
visually as men do.
I don't know whether I have the male gaze
or what, but I totally understand this.
There's this charge in female sexuality.
Young women today want to wield the power
of female sexuality without then accepting
the consequences of it.
Christina: That's right, and I think what
we're seeing now on the campus is we've had
this hyper puritanism, this policing of sexuality
and then all of these functionaries, the apparatchiks,
the universities...I read the University of
North Carolina has 40 or 50 sexual harassment,
sexual assault...
Camille: Oh, my.
What a waste of money.
Christina: ...work shoppers and they're busy.
Camille: Parasites.
Christina: They go back and forth to conferences.
They get new ideas.
Camille: Horrible.
Christina: It used to be that a lot of theories
they objected to, they were inspired by French
philosophy and there was a lot of obscure
nonsense.
Now a lot of the scholarship is driven by
these apparatchiks, some with functionaries
in university and their little findings, which
is all propaganda, advocacy research.
So it turns out that Swarthmore is a rape
culture.
Camille: Oh, for heaven's sakes.
Christina: And where on earth are women more...
Camille: A Quaker school.
It's ridiculous.
Christina: ...safer.
They now have, these sexual harassment, assault
counselors they have fact books and little
videos, and they bring kids in for orientation,
and tell them they actually describe the campus,
"It's as dangerous at Oberlin and at Wesleyan
as war-torn Congo."
Camille: It’s absurd.
Christina: So the young women are frightened,
so they've introduced so much paranoia.
Camille: Yeah, it's the bureaucrats.
Christina: And the culture of blame and young
men can be destroyed simply by being accused
in...
Camille: The kangaroo courts, absolutely.
Christina: ...the kangaroo courts.
Camille: The bureaucrats have taken over the
universities.
The faculty also have very critically lost
power over the past 30 to 40 years.
The faculty has been utterly passive and not
pushing back against all of this.
Christina: Where have they been?
When we were talking...
Camille: Utter wimps.
Christina: ...20-21 years ago, I thought for
sure more scholars would come forward.
Because I do believe that this panic, this
Salem witch trial atmosphere, it was created
by scholars working with university functionaries,
but it's going to take scholars to stop it.
Where are they?
Camille: Yes, that's right.
They're afraid.
There's a fear.
Now once you tangle with the bureaucrats,
they have all the power and now with federal
regulations behind it, it's intrusive.
I'm hoping Congress is going to roll this
back, this over-interpretation of Title IX.
Christina: Back in the 1990s, when we were
winning the argument, and we had the support
of the media, there were all these great writers,
that took our side, pro free speech, and it
was taken for granted, and people would make
fun of the courses.
They would look at the MLA and there would
be these silly courses on, I don't know...cross-dressing
and medieval Valencia or autoeroticism in
the early Jane Austen.
It was fun, and then the media got a little
tired of it, and thought it had gone away.
It didn't go away.
It got much worse.
And if you look at the curriculum now and
the courses that kids take...on Twitter there's
a Twitter called Peer Review and all he does
is report abstracts, show abstracts in journals.
It's so shocking, and it never ends, and you'd
think they've reached the ultimate of madness.
Just to give an example and this isn't the
worst, Feminist Glaciology.
It's a feminist study of glaciers.
It draws on feminist post Colonialism, and
feminist political ecology.
What are these fields?
There's a field, Feminist Political Ecology.
What do they read?
It must just be slogans, and mixed with a
little propaganda, a little paranoia thrown
in.
One course after the other, so are they taking
History of Western Civilization?
Are they learning about art?
Do they know major historical figures?
No, but they could talk about these arcane,
little propaganda, stick topics.
Camille: Yes, the core curriculum was abandoned
as these new micro-fields came in.
Women's studies, African-American studies
and so on, and identity politics, they changed
the curriculum in the 1970s, and then all
of a sudden the whole history of Western art,
well, that's classist, it's racist, so we
have to abandon that.
And so what you have now is a whole generation,
in fact two generations probably of graduate
students who are incapable, actually of ever
teaching in a broad, narrative way, the old,
wonderful survey courses.
Christina: Right.
Camille: Now what I'm calling for is an attack
on upon the curriculum, a reduction by 60%
of these elected, these silly electives to
be thrown out, and a compulsory return to
teaching within these core ideas that are
oriented toward ancient to modern.
Because another thing that, in addition to
what you just mentioned, the fragmentation,
is that too many courses now are dated in
the present, the present from after the Enlightenment
or even after the 19th century.
So you have an imbalance in the curriculum,
so that young people have no sense of the
ancient civilizations, and the way they rose
and fell over time.
They have no idea of the world.
They think that all the evils of the world
are isolated in Western culture.
They have no idea about the atrocities, and
the oppressions of empires all over the world.
So what we need to do I discovered in my students
coming from a broad range of preparations,
now and then there'll be private schools,
but mostly they come from good suburban schools
or from bad inner city schools and they know
absolutely nothing about the chronology of
human life.
Hence, they look around them, and they see
things that are flaws in our current system,
and they believe that these flaws can be fixed,
and that all other cultures in the history
of the world were somehow a paradise on earth,
and we're enjoying the most liberties, ever
as women.
Christina: These cultures and all these students
who are so hostile to the United States because
it's a capitalist, hetero, patriarchal, oppressive,
imperialist system, these sorts of terms are
taken seriously.
Well, compared to what?
What other country?
We're far from perfect, but we're a struggling
democracy that's done more to address racism,
and classism, and sexism than any country
I'm aware of.
But it's almost as if they don't know that.
Camille: I know it.
Christina: They don't know that we have experimented
with systems that don't have free markets
and they didn't work out very well.
These students don't seem to know that.
They don't know the history of Communism.
Camille: Oh, they have no sense of economics
or much less, political theory.
Christina: Economic illiteracy.
And so they're very confidently and they've
been taught in their classes, and what astonishes
me is someone who as a professor of many years,
I always thought it was a sacred commandment,
"Thou shalt teach both sides of the argument."
So in any philosophy class, I would make sure
whatever we were studying, I'd try to bring
the best that was thought and said on both
sides.
Well, in these classrooms, in many classrooms
and especially anthropology, sociology, not
philosophy...philosophy is so far immune to
this, although it has other problems...
Camille: Literature, throughout the humanities.
Christina: ...literature, and then of course,
gender studies, all the ethnic studies classes
it's largely one point of view.
They have their doctrinal feuds, but it's
the gamut from A to B, they leave out all
other perspectives.
Conservatives aren't there, heaven forbid,
libertarian perspectives, not there.
Commonsense has no place, and so the students
have this sense that they've been exposed
to what they take to be settled knowledge.
It's not settled.
Camille: Well, this is another thing I'm calling
for is that the profession has not paid sufficient
attention to this question of advocacy in
the classroom.
I think that it's important that teacher's
have opinions inside the classroom.
However they have an obligation, an ethical
and professional obligation, to identify what
they're saying as opinion and to state openly
to the class that every person in the class,
has the right to express a contrary opinion
and to hold it without the rest of the class
scorning it or creating a hostile environment,
etc., but that's totally gone from the profession.
The idea, the ethics of teaching, the ethics
of teaching, as well as the ethics of research
are no longer a subject of study by the profession
itself.
Christina: Oh, this is very important to bring
back, and just in terms of effective teaching
what I'd love to do because I loved it as
a student...you'll remember this.
This was especially true in philosophy.
You would read a set of philosophers, let's
suppose philosophers defending free will in
a metaphysics course, and either you'd tend
to agree with them as you read them, then
the teacher would switch and you'd read the
determinist, and the critiques, and then you
would say, "How did I ever believe that?"
And you'd have that wonderful, intellectual
experience of changing your mind or realizing
that, "I'd been wrong.
Now I'm right.
Maybe I'm wrong."
Then you develop this sense of some humility
that you have to take into account a full
range of opinion.
This is what I did in my philosophy class
and this is what every textbook I ever saw
in philosophy does.
But on one occasion, this is probably what
prompted me to start criticizing feminism,
the chair of my department asked me to teach
a Women's Studies course, Feminist Theory
and I sent away for textbooks.
I thought, "Okay.
I'll teach it.
I'm a feminist.
I'm a philosopher.
I'll teach feminist philosophy."
I assumed, I don't know what I thought, I
thought it would be historical figures saying
some terrible things and some good things,
and then I thought maybe it was people pro
and con abortion or surrogate motherhood,
affirmative action.
No, what is was, was a series of rather paranoid
texts.
These were feminist philosophers writing these
really...but they were ideologues.
The readings were mutually reinforcing and
there was a lot of false data.
That's where I became...I alerted to the role
of propaganda.
You take these sensitive, mostly young women
in these Women's Studies classes they hear
that one in four of them will be raped, that
they're going to cheated out of 25% of their
salary and they have a massive loss of self-esteem,
and that's only if they're not already dead
from an eating disorder caused by patriarchal
standards of beauty.
They learn this.
These sorts of things were in the textbooks,
and I was just appalled at the lack of balance,
and as I said, the propaganda and the ideology.
So that's when I went to the American Philosophical
Association criticizing it, and I thought
like at other times I'd been there, you argue.
It's combat, and I was prepared for that and
then you go out for drinks.
That's typically what happens.
Well, we did not go out for drinks.
The room was full of feminist philosophers.
Some were hissing, stamping their feet, and
I was excommunicated from a religion, I didn't
know existed.
And then it was the year or two after that,
I think I was reading The New York Times,
it was about this woman, Camille Paglia, I
wasn't sure how to pronounce it, and I was
riveted and soon after you spoke at MIT.
It was a rainy night.
I went out to Brookline, and I had a little
child at home, and there was nothing to keep
me away and the room was filled, all of them
MIT.
Camille: Thousands of people came down.
Christina: They had video screens in the hall,
so students could see.
Camille: People came from all over in the
Boston area.
Christina: We were there.
Camille: They had the police there to handle
the crowd.
Christina: Yeah, they had the police there,
and I think that evening, you may have deprogrammed
a thousand students.
You were there, and you were just telling
the truth.
Camille: Well, half of the crowd was against,
half was for.
I felt like I was steering a ship on a stormy
sea.
I did some of my best improv comedy ever that
night.
Christina: Oh, you were...
Camille: I was putting on all...
Christina: If only we had that on tape.
These days we'd have you on YouTube, get millions
of views.
Camille: There's a transcript of it in my
Sex Art book.
Christina: It was one of the most thrilling,
intellectual experiences in my life, and for
all those students, and I remember there were
a group of people, I forget, they had a name
for themselves.
They were all dressed in black, and they came
to protest your views, I guess, on date rape
or something and they came, and they were
going to make trouble.
But then they were so outnumbered, and they
were mesmerized by you, and I watched as they
quietly melted away.
Camille: You see because they were very used
to disrupting speakers who read prepared texts,
and I do improv in controversial situations,
and it's very difficult to deal with because
everything negative that came from the floor,
I would just do something with it and throw
it right back.
Christina: Well, that's the way to do it.
Camille: I was trained in the school of Joan
Rivers at that point.
Christina: Oh, that's the way to do it.
As God is my witness, I will not read a speech
again.
It's actually not a good idea.
It's better just to talk to the audience.
So this is what happened.
A couple weeks ago, I went to UMass, Amherst
and I was there with Milo Yiannopoulos, who
is this provocateur, satirist, self-described
shit poster and just funny and he says provocative
things to me, not to everyone and I have to
correct him.
He does go too far.
So he's sort of like it's not really good
cop, bad cop.
It's more like concerned mother and wayward
son, and we've gone to a few campuses together
and then we had a comedian, this wonderful
comedian, Steve Crowder.
So there were three of us.
As soon as we come on, people in the audience
just burst out, they start screeching, and
yelling, and then Milo says something and
he's doing what you say.
He makes some...I won't repeat what Milo said,
but that provoked him, and then I went up
as Based Mom to be reasonable, I thought.
Well, I upset them.
They were screaming even more.
They were using foul language.
It's all on tape, so it's gone viral.
But there was not a moment that they weren't
screaming, and I don't know where the campus
police were.
Apparently this is permitted, but at one point
Milo said, "We're not going away.
We're here.
We're going to give our talk," and then the
comedian did this little riff.
He was angry at them and that's also gone
viral on the internet.
But my hope is that...so this has all been
covered by the conservative press, not a word
in The New York Times, not a word in The New
Republic or on Slate.
The liberal media is not paying attention,
so I'm very concerned.
I mean the last time we had the help of the
liberal media that didn't work, so maybe not
having them, maybe it doesn't matter.
But I'm just wondering who's going to come
forward and defend just free speech.
Where is that right now?
Where is the movement?
Where are the Nat Hentoff's?
Well, Nat Hentoff is still there, but in those
days we had just so many people coming forward
and defending free speech.
Then you had people...
Camille: I think there has to be pressure
on the colleges and universities themselves,
to maintain an atmosphere for civil discourse
and for hospitality to guests of any political
persuasion, and without that kind of backbone
coming from the college administrators themselves,
I think this is going on.
But I feel that there's slowly a sense of
things turning.
The seriousness of it is starting.
To become aware...
Christina: I think so, too.
Camille: ...that this is really getting absurd
now.
Christina: And I also think some of the...not
some...I think a lot of the millennials, because
it's a scrappy generation, and it's also they're
all connected on the internet and so they
talk to each other we haven't heard from them
yet.
I think every generation faces a threat to
freedom.
You always have to fight for it.
The '50s, you had the McCarthy era and earlier
generations, there's always movements that
come along, and have good reasons why someone
should have to shut up and keep quiet, so
these censorship campaigns.
So this generation is being challenged, and
I think I'm seeing signs of rebellion.
Camille: I don't think students realize the
kind of power that they have for pushback
against the college administrations.
They keep on accepting all of this paternalism,
this suffocating, all enveloping paternalism.
Christina: Right, I think the activists, the
social justice warriors on campus they know
the power they have over administrators.
Camille: Yes, that's right.
Christina: Someone taped a young woman going
into an office at Vassar College demanding
a copy of the...it was a setup.
There was someone filming this poor administrator,
really.
So this pretend student went in with a copy
of the U.S. Constitution, I think it was Vassar
and she wanted it shredded because it was
triggering.
And the conservative media had a good time
with it because it was showing that here's
an administrator that would shred the Constitution.
That's not what I saw in the tape.
I saw a frightened administrator.
Terrified of this young woman, probably thinking,
"Am I going to lose my job if this doesn't...?"
and she was a hostage.
This administrator was like a frightened hostage,
and this is what I think, so what I want the
millennials to understand, the social justice
activists and the Safe Space people on campus,
they are pressuring and frightening the administrators
who are giving into them which is nothing
these administrators should be proud of.
But it's time for a pushback from the students
who value free speech, who value rational
scholarship, who would like to be free individuals,
and to stop the policing of sexuality.
All of these things have to be fought for
again.
Camille: That's right, absolutely.
Yeah, so there has to be a new movement, a
new Free Speech Movement in my view.
There has to be.
It has to come from the students, as it did
the first time with Mario Savio at Berkeley.
Christina: I was just going say we need the
Mario Savio's, and at that time they had a
lot to lose too, because that's what the students
will tell you.
They'll tell you, "Your college is so expensive,
and if I get in trouble..." and now you can
be marked, as a rape cultural apologist or
a racist simply by challenging, simply by
asking for open debate, you can be...there's
a lot of stigma.
Camille: Well, the administrators, they are
now running essentially a business.
The colleges are all competitive with each
other.
They're desperate for tuition dollars, so
the bureaucrats are all about protecting the
PR image of the university.
So they want to be on the politically correct
side of protecting those who have suffered
from racial or gender injustice in the past,
etc.
There really is this...speak of sanctimonious,
there's this puffed up view of themselves.
They're somehow part of the progressive movement
of social justice in the universe, by suppressing
people who have dissident views on campus.
Christina: You can't even get...and I've been
writing about this for years, as you know.
There's now this set of...it's just a body
of egregiously false information at the heart
of campus radicalism, particularly campus
feminism, and 21 years ago we were talking
about false statistics on rape, false statistics
on the wage gap.
This wage gap is still going on.
Camille: It will never go away.
It's so ridiculous.
Christina: This one statistician said a phony
statistic is harder to kill than a vampire
once it's out.
A false feminist statistic is the hardest
to kill of all.
Camille: It's unbelievable.
Christina: It is beyond the reach of rational
analysis.
Camille: No one understands that, for heaven's
sakes, John Kennedy signed the Equal Pay bill,
it was like decades ago.
It was a half century ago and there are very
rare cases of a woman being paid less than
a man for doing the same job.
Christina: The same job.
Camille: Okay.
Right, the same job.
They don't understand this.
It's so simple, a simple point.
Christina: No responsible economist would
tell you otherwise.
Camille: Oh, my Lord.
Christina: Yet, when I say this on campus,
shrieks.
And some young woman at Oberlin I remember
as saying, "If you want to make as much as
a man, you should change your major because
on average men are more likely to study these
highly remunerative fields, petroleum engineering
or naval architecture."
And I just said to the Oberlin student, "You
know if you study feminist dance therapy you
might not earn as much."
Oh, my goodness, they were outraged at the
idea that they couldn't study what they wanted,
and then earn as much and so forth.
They carry on, but it's we've got this propaganda.
There's no way to correct it and then you
get shouted down on campus, if you even suggest...
Camille: Well, the biggest gap in Women's
Studies is the failure to have a requirement
about biology.
Christina: Oh, well that.
Camille: Because there's no reference to biology.
You've had 40 years of Women's Studies with
a social constructionist view of gender without
the slightest reference to hormones or endocrinology
or anything else.
Christina: Exactly.
Forty years of Women's Studies, and I think
we know less about gender than we did at the
start of it, for this very reason.
This dogma, oh, that men and women are the
same, that we're cognitively interchangeable.
Camille: We're blank slates at birth, and
society inscribes gender on us.
It's absurd.
Christina: As one feminist philosopher said
many years ago, "We're all born bisexual,
and then through socialization, we're transformed
into gendered human beings, one destined to
command, the other to obey."
I once read that to my husband who said, "Which
one commands and which obeys?"
Camille: There you go.
Christina: For heaven's sakes, I'm someone
who was writing a dissertation on androgyny
and I never for one moment in my entire life
have questioned that the sexes are actually
different, and that there's a very powerful,
hormonal compulsion that drives the sexes
together for our procreation, hello, okay.
Camille: And it's so obvious and people say,
"Well, what's the evidence?"
Well, let's start with the entire anthropological
record or just look at a magazine rack and
it's clear that men are looking, on average,
I'm not talking about all men and all women,
but on average, there are different propensities.
Christina: Men have 8 to 10 times the amount
of testosterone circulating in their bodies
than women do.
As if there aren't consequences, but of course,
this subject is something utterly untouched
in gender studies.
You're going to graduate with a degree in
Women's Studies and know nothing about it.
Camille: Nothing about it.
Christina: Nothing.
Camille: Nothing to know and so they are,
at any time they find statistical disparity
between men and women, any field, if there
are more male petroleum engineers, it has
to be discrimination.
Camille: Right, it can't be women's free choice
for any reason.
Christina: Free choice and that on average
women are interested in other things.
Camille: Absolutely and also women want more
flexibility in their lives to allow for children...
Christina: Children.
Camille: ...but that's not also part of the
feminist equation.
Christina: Oh, and if we don't have a special
bond with children...It's so absurd the denial
of nature, the denial of femininity and masculinity.
Camille: Absolutely.
Christina: Which for most people, it's a source
of enjoyment and if you are conventionally
feminine, you enjoy that typically and the
same with male, and you enjoy a masculine
man.
And all of this is now either denied or there's
this aura of disapproval around conventional
sexuality and there's so little pushback in
the Academy.
Camille: Well, it's because there's no knowledge,
and people are just settled and sluggish within
their little selves, their ideological selves
and there really are very few truly inquiring
minds left, no true intellectuals, really
in the Academy.
The Academy and, of course the colleges and
universities, have never been known for producing
free thinkers.
It is after all a bureaucratic entity the
Academy.
If we want intellectuals, the present system
is certainly not the way to produce them.
Christina: I'm just wondering, "What is this
generation?
Are we going to have some great public intellectuals
coming forth, who aren't just spouting dogma?"
Camille: You'd think that the web would allow
people to have free and independent though,
but no.
Christina: No, you have all these people...
Camille: Yeah, everyone is so grouped and
clustered.
Christina: ...and these little Twitter moms
that are policing everyone.
Camille: Oh, absolutely.
Christina: You'll have these incidents.
This poor comet scientist who wore the wrong
shirt to a press conference, and then they
were hysterical on the internet, to punish
him and censor him, and these kinds of happen.
Camille: Parochialism of their minds.
The banality of their minds.
Christina: I know exactly what you're saying.
Why aren't there more people like us?
Why don't more people see it?
Camille: Well, we're the product of a certain
time.
I realize that now and I'm trying actually
not to be too hard on the young people today
because they didn't have our kind of background.
Our parents...
Christina: The comedians, Mort Saul and Lenny
Bruce, and then George Gavin.
Camille: Carlin, comedians were tremendous.
Christina: Richard Pryor and so today the
comedians aren't allowed on campus.
Camille: Yes, that's right.
Christina: They're triggering.
They don't want to go.
Camille: Humor comes from violating taboos.
All right, we could have a taboo about women
or race or anything else, then you you're
attracting humor toward it.
Any rigidity attracts humor because satire
breaks up the rigidity.
Christina: So anyway my question here is,
I think these propaganda and the denial that
there are differences between the sexes they're
just built up.
It's a big lie and it's almost to me, comparable...I
can't carry out this analogy too far.
But the credit default swaps and there was
all of these bad mortgages distributed everywhere.
No one knew where they were, but they were
everywhere in the economy and then it brought
it down, and I see this as feminist misinformation.
We have feminist misinformation in every area,
disseminated by these credulous journalists
who don't ask the right questions.
So everybody believes sexes are exactly the
same and there's this wage gap.
That there's rape culture on campus.
That women are victims and men are...all of
this is out there.
Large numbers of people believing something
that's just not true.
Camille: Well, you have to realize that a
lot of people in the media now are products
of those PC elite schools.
I encounter them all the time.
Christina: So do I.
Camille: And trying to get their minds to
focus, they have an utterly...I'm talking
about Yale degrees, Harvard degrees, Princeton
degrees.
Christina: Oh, the more prestigious the degree,
the more likely it is.
Camille: The worse, absolutely.
Their minds are like...
Christina: Whole generation of young women...
Camille: ...they can't focus.
They have no knowledge, and they're in media.
They're writing The New York Times, they're
doing political analysis in The New York Times.
They know nothing.
Christina: They know nothing, but they have
a lot of confidence, very high self-esteem.
Camille: Yes, because...
Christina: No problem there.
Camille: ...they have these bright and shiny
degrees, which are in fact, meaningless and
valueless.
Christina: Worthless.
Camille: Worthless degrees, worthless Ivy
League degrees.
Christina: They should go back.
They should go, I don't know.
Camille: Remember I used to say that Naomi
Wolf, her parents should have sued Yale for
mal-education.
Christina: Susan Faludi's parents should have
sued for...
Camille: Susan Faludi and Naomi Wolf, these
are two very smart women, who were defrauded
by their elite school education.
Look how their careers have tanked.
Why is that?
They didn't have the solid, rigorous education
you and I did.
I went to the State University of New York
at Binghamton.
I had a superb education in the basics, and
that is fueling my productivity at my stage
of life, but look at Susan Faludi and Naomi
Wolf.
They started out so strong, and there's nothing
because they have nothing underneath it.
Christina: I identify with them in this way.
I came from Southern California in the hippie
era, I was a flower child, so if I had come
to college and they had courses in witchcraft
I was interested in that.
My friend in high school was Mimi Simo [SP]
she became a witch.
She was a brilliant girl, but she became Star
Hawk, and I don't know.
We were friends, but then she became...maybe
we could still be friends.
I wouldn't want her to put a hex on me.
But I went to NYU, and if they'd had kooky
majors, I would have gone in for them.
I would have been a witchcraft major maybe.
But the most interesting thing I could find
was philosophy and my philosophy professors
at NYU it was clear thinking and rigor and
precision rules, and coming as a flower...I
thought it was far out.
We read this book called Language, Truth,
and Logic by A.J.
Ayer.
It was a very extreme statement of the need
for a logical rigor in your thought, and so
forth, and I loved it.
I fell in love with it, and I slowly class
after class I had, reading the great philosophers,
and I slowly became a disciplined thinker.
I like to think that I did, but I always knew
how I once saw the world, and then the transformation.
Of course, that's what I hoped to do in the
classroom.
What I see now is that 17-year-old, 18-year-old
Christina coming from the California flower
child culture, and a lot of kids are coming
from all sorts of backgrounds, but you come
to school, it would be reinforced.
It would be catered to, and I could have run
to the dean and said, "I'm not really getting
the courses that I would like to take."
You can design your own major.
Camille: That's right, it's cafeteria style
now.
Christina: It's cafeteria style and it's even
in the museums now.
Camille: Oh, absolutely.
Ah, the museums, horrible.
Christina: The museums, I was in Portland
and to the local museum, and there was a beautiful
display of some Indian artifacts and some
exquisite photographs of Indians, Native Americans,
and the works of art it was all beautiful.
But in every room, there was some feminist
art historian had written a hectoring, little
description censoring and talking about the
gaze of the tourist and all this kind of deconstruction,
and so you couldn't learn about the art, and
you couldn't enjoy it.
It had to be mediated through the mind of
this fanatical...
Camille: Ideological perspective.
It had to be filtered through, the judgementalism,
the moralism, the guilt tripping and so on.
Christina: It was one big guilt trip.
Camille: Instead of the actual encounter with
an artifact from the past, and a sense of
awe and reverence before that object, no we
have to have this interposed contemporary
figure hectoring us.
That's the sermon.
They're new preachers, the new scolds, perfect.
Christina: They're scolds.
Camille: They're new scolds.
They're pests.
So we see it going into the media, that's
a given, and now in the museums and then there's
cultural appropriation.
This is one of the new ideas that if you,
at some level a lot of this there's a kernel
of wisdom, that you don't put on black face
and essentially demean another culture in
that way.
But now they're going after yoga classes and
that sort of thing, you're not supposed to
say Namaste.
That's going to put all of Portland out of
work.
It's nothing but yoga studios, I don't know.
But now performances of the Mikado, the Gilbert
and Sullivan, people are saying, "Well, that
was cultural appropriation.
It's demeaning."
You have the museum in Boston where they have
beautiful kimonos on display.
Well, now there were protesters and the protesters
didn't seem to be from Japan.
It's almost always people that aren't in that
culture that are the most shrill.
Camille: Oh, good Lord.
Christina: And so the Boston Museum, the Museum
of Fine Arts had to apologize.
Camille: Oh, I don't believe it.
Christina: So this is going on.
It's permeating the culture and I want it
to stop.
Camille: Yes, that's right.
It's so unsophisticated.
This is not the way.
Christina: Anti-intellectual.
Camille: This is not the way you contemplate
history and art, through the contemporary
political filter.
This distorts the meaning of history and art.
Christina: It distorts and trivializes, and
that's what I see with students.
They're not having these encounters with great
works of art.
Camille: Right.
Christina: That's what a teacher should do.
Camille: We were produced by the great books
curriculum.
Christina: We always had, no matter what even
if you had a bad teacher you always had a
classic.
Camille: And a sense of respect for the greatness
of the work, not this debunking, sneering
deconstruction.
Christina: Now they have a sense of superiority.
Camille: Exactly.
"Oh, this is like a product of all kinds of
outmoded or racial or gender paradigms," and
so on.
Give me a break.
The whole history of the world is seen through
this contemporary lens, and again, it's absolutely...and
that's we're not getting any important intellectuals
and young intellectuals, young writers, young
analysts.
If you're ever going to get any they have
got to start going back to the library and
finding other independent thinkers because
they're certainly not being presented with
them in the classroom.
Christina: They're just not.
Camille: No.
Christina: So that's the message to students
today.
You cannot depend on your...
Camille: Don't depend on the teachers.
Christina: ...teachers.
Camille: No, distrust authority.
Resist authority and go and find what you
need in the library and don't just sit there
on rear end in front of the computer because
the computer self-selects for you.
You're not going to find it.
You have to go and physically engage with
the things on the shelves.
It's what I did.
I ransacked the Yale University Library.
Christina: Someone called our universities,
"Islands of repression in a sea of freedom."
Students have to liberate their islands.
So we're here foment rebellion.
Camille: That's right.
That's right.
Christina: Well, thank you, Camille.
Camille: Well, great, Christina, as usual.
Christina: So I'm hoping we meet...
Camille: We always agree.
Christina: ...20 years from now and oh, goodness.
Camille: That's right.
Okay.
Christina: It'll be free again and liberated.
Camille: Let's hope free speech is restored.
Christina: Yes, and sanity.
Well, thank you